40 عاما والعراقيون ينتظرون استقبال هذه
البطوله وهاهم على بعد ساعات بدء العرس
الخليجيه في البصره الفيحاء
منذ شهرين والعراق يواصل استعداداته
المكثفه لاستضافه كاس الخليج جوانب خدميه
واخرى تنظيميه وكرنفالات الرياضيه في
بغداد والبصره اهل الفن ايضا دخلوا على خط
البطوله من خلال اغانيهم التي عبرت عن كرم
العراقيين وحبهم للخليجي واهله
نشعب واحد ارض بحر
صوت وصدى واحد والعالم يسمع عسل
[موسيقى]
من الفنانين العراقيين
وهنالك عمل من انتاج نقابه الفنانين
العراقيين بشكل مباشر وهو للفنان نجاح عبد
الغفور
كان له بصمه في هذه البطوله من خلال
اغنيته هلا بجيتكم هلا
هلا
جاياتكم هلا هلا هلا هلا هلا هلا
جاكم هلا
يحييكم شط العرب هلال
جمهور متعطش هنا في بغداد العديد منهم لم
يستطع الوصول الى البصره او حجز التذاكر
لكنه سيدعم ويشجع وربما يتوقع من الفائز
بالبطوله مبكرا ما حصلت تذاكر مع الاسف بس
ان شاء الله هنكون متواجدين نشجعهم قالبا
وقلبا بالله البغدادي ان شاء الله منطقه
الكراده اتوقع ان شاء الله المنتخب
العراقي او المنتخب السعودي واذا المنتخب
السعودي اخذها في همم ما راحت الغريب وان
شاء الله ان شاء الله ياخذوا المنتخب
العراقي
[موسيقى]
فنانون على مختلف الوانهم قدموا الدعم من
خلال اصواتهم والحانهم لانجاح هذه البطوله
كما وعد العراقيون بان تكون هذه النسخه
الاجمل من خلال التنظيم والجمهور وان تكون
كرنفالا خليجيا لكن هذه المره بنكهه
عراقيه سامر الكبيسي العربيه بغداد